[Music]
you are listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan's here
that's a lot of spanish guys thank you
for tuning in thanks for making my
podcast a uh a choice that you've made
uh i appreciate that i appreciate you
listening um if you could write a review
if you like the episode if you're here
for leslie ann brant who's great on the
episode hopefully you're listening now
and if you like it you'll subscribe to
the podcast write a review follow us on
our handles which are patent-side if you
pod on twitter outside of your podcast
on instagram and facebook that is
absolutely true ryan yep um it really
helps the podcast that when you write a
review and and and listen that's all i
have to say i want to say thank you to
all my patrons out there join
patreon.com inside of you if you want to
uh give back to the podcast many people
give back there's different tiers i give
little gifts and notes and it's a
community patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash inside of you if you want
any merch go to the inside of you online
store tons of great stuff from
smallville script sign to lunchbox
smallville sign to uh inside of you mugs
and inside you tumblers and and lots of
great things so also pictures
autographed pictures so head out to the
inside of you online store
and uh you know great episode today also
i'm going to be at some conventions
coming up okay uh
st louis missouri i believe i don't you
know i don't know when this is going to
air
so oh this is this there's tuesday
jesus i forgot
um i will be in um st louis coming up i
will be in illinois metropolis illinois
june i think believe
10th
and 11th tom welling will be with me
then i go to australia from the 17th for
two weeks so make sure you get your
tickets to sydney or perth uh
and so on and so forth i think i'll be
in liverpool in may as well so anyway
leslie ann brandt is fantastic she's
fantastic on the show lucifer which is a
huge has a huge huge following oh yeah
well it wasn't that was one of the
biggest shows on netflix last year isn't
that something if not the biggest and
you never would have thought that
because it's a show that i've never
really seen well it came from network tv
and then it got put on netflix and it
just blew up people love this show and
uh
good for them good for her i'm glad it's
such a success and we get into a lot
about the show we get into a lot about
her fitness and her well-being and
everything you know she was completely
open and honest and i loved loved having
her on the show so without further ado
let's get inside of leslie anne brandt
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
the older you get the more tender you
get
the more the more fragile vulnerable all
of this so that's the thing with you
know
our age my age you're younger than i am
but a lot younger than i am how old are
you i'll be 50. in general so is chris
are going to be 50 in march and i just
turned 40.
wow 40. yeah you don't look 40. well
thanks you really don't uh but yeah the
big full um it's the skin oh thank you
the skin's just really supple soft
thanks yeah you know i put a lot of
effort into
moisturizing and sunscreen and how
important is that i never did that till
i was in my 40s you should listen so
bulbar does we have you said bill burr
yeah the comedian okay so we i
uh
i went out for dinner with him and his
wife because our kids go to school
together and you know we it was like new
year's eve
and um but he has this great joke where
he talks about like ashy skin because
his wife was like you need to moisturize
dude like
you're like about to like like you're
like a kindling right now you know but
he was like he was saying like yeah when
i go back to massachusetts uh
like guys look so much older because
they're not moisturizing that's true are
you listening to this if you guys are
listening if you get anything from this
podcast today i'm telling you
moisturizing changed my life yes my
friend chris was like rose mom because
that's how he talked to that rosy mom
yeah you're a moisturized man you have
to moisturize you live in california
it's dry sunscreen
and then as we age you know texture
changes well i get those spots now i'm
getting spots on my head like little
like discoloration so would you have to
go get those burnt off or something
spots yeah you don't get those do you no
well you know my melanin challenged
friend you know i have some natural
apprentices
yeah yeah you've uh
yeah because you grew up in south africa
and it was is it pretty hot there
usually yeah it's very hot
[Music]
i mean very hot um it no we have four
seasons right you know so we do have
like autumn and winter and uh
fall as you guys call it over here fall
um
but i like the accent don't you ryan
it is let me hear the the
the real the real south african accent
is not sexy i mean can you imagine going
to bed with someone like this and being
like put it in me right now
it's not cute
it's not cute we juggle me and my
friends joke about that all the time
now do a lot of people talk like that
when you go back that's how they talk no
my accent when i go back this is exactly
what i sound like with my family you do
that
it's like it's like an automatic thing
and
now that we're talking about south
africa my south african accent will come
out more and then when i'm around
because my parents live in new zealand i
moved to new zealand and i was just like
two weeks before my 18th birthday then
when i'm around my kiwi friends or
australians then i sound like more like
a kiwi
you could do so many accents yeah let me
hear no i can't no don't do that don't
do that thing here well new zealand new
zealand yeah kiwis yeah how do they
sound you know like how how are you man
right now
but but not like but not like australian
can be very more like twangy like i
didn't really understand the difference
between us people get upset by that yes
and then i went to
then i flew
uh to new zealand uh i flew to australia
on qantas and i heard the dif the
difference between this and this
this and this yeah like uh please place
anything you have to declare and the
declaration been like this
kiwis are like
yeah so so and kiwis are like yeah i'm
going to go get some fashion shops
say that again
shop
wow that's such a subtle chopsticks fish
and sharks yeah man yeah it's it's
almost like owen wilson was doing it
yeah
no but i love accents i used to prank
call when i was like
i don't know
10 years old called people
yes like like what do you mean like i
used to prank call people too yeah but i
would just do accents
like i was 10 years old and the thing is
my parents to get really pissed off
because back in the day we're talking
like you know early 90s you paid for
every call in south africa that you made
who are these people that you've been
calling exactly i don't know exactly i
don't know who they are but it served me
well when i moved to la because that's
how i practice my american accent was
just to be american for a day you know
jump into american right just go ahead
keep oh come on
this is fun
i mean i wish i could do a bunch of i
mean i could do some stuff but like you
know usually they're important i'll give
you an example when i went and did my
audition for lucifer i went in exactly
like this i just was conversationally
american i had no idea i would have
thought where would you say she was from
when she's talking like this ryan go
ahead keep talking natural oh it's cal
it's california kind of california
california yeah oregon maybe or
oregon
just you know uh yeah no i used to
that's how i that's how i fooled them
and then at the end of the audition i'd
be like oh well thanks guys and they're
like wait you're not from here i think
they like that yeah i think they like
hiring
you know like someone who comes and does
american accent oh they're english oh
they're australian oh they're but they
don't and they can just turn it on and
turn it off it's something it's like oh
that's a real actor who can do that yeah
well
i mean the thing about it which i think
is sometimes like it's hard for
you we grow up with american television
so you know from a young age i was i
mean i was watching american tv so i got
to practice and if you have it here for
it musically then you know but you guys
don't grow up watching south african tv
no
i mean most people confuse like a kiwi
accent with british
and it's very different what was your
favorite american tv show growing up ooh
don't say beverly hills 902 no
all right no
i loved moda she wrote murders
i know um i wanted angela lansbury to be
my grandmother so bad wow um do you know
i've never seen an episode of that what
how dare you i've seen golden girls how
dare you i've never said how dare have
you seen murder she wrote no should i
watch it does it hold up yes yes think
it's mysteries right crime solving
grandma with a typewriter is she still
alive she yes she didn't she do she did
um
mary poppins
mary poppins she did the remake of
mirror pushers and you know selling the
balloons oh really i didn't know that do
you know that
right the only way is up like the only
she sang that song really
i don't know have you ever do you sing
yes what do you mean you say i thought i
read something where you were you're a
singer no i'm not i mean i mean i can't
hold a tune i
it's like
it's like saying
uh
so i've sung
four times on tv
right for the show but i don't say i'm a
singer i can just like hold a tune so
you know when you're flat you know when
you're like sharp if i'm off key i know
you know that yeah but i mean in terms
of like will i go and cut an album
no really i'm not a great singer and
i've cut two albums i'm working on my
third how dare you i i am trying to live
my dreams stop it and i just don't care
i'm here to crush your dreams do not be
a dream crusher i got a friend of tom
my buddy tom lally and every time you
say anything he'll just crush your
dreams we call him the dream crusher
really he could say something like dude
i'm getting my house painted tomorrow
and the guy gave me a great deal how
much
and i tell him he's like
you can get so much better than that
yeah dream crusher yeah little things
like that rain clouds that's what i call
them yeah
yeah but he's
know available i've learned is to just
have different expectations of people so
if i'm in a and that's some advice that
my
my uh a really good friend gave me
because i think you're just you then you
don't open yourself up to anything right
so you just go hey
if i'm feeling down and i want to wallow
in some [ __ ] i'ma call you so you know
what you're getting yeah you're like oh
we're both going to complain for an hour
yeah that's what this is about yeah or
just uh you know give people permission
to do it or you yourself i always check
myself like that like if i'm
disappointed about something or upset
about something give myself permission
to feel what i feel
but then don't wallow in the [ __ ] for
too long yeah that's the danger you know
we as actors are i mean i just in
general i think
i'm very sensitive to energy like that
you know because i because i know
i know where i can go if i allow myself
to so i you know i just do things too
how far can you go
well you just get i mean
i remember when i first moved over to
l.a and like i moved by myself
left my family how old were you
it was like before my 30th i think like
well so you haven't lived here that long
twelve years okay this is my 12 year
12th year all right
i mean i think hello [ __ ] i think i've
like earned my spot in l.a i'm not
saying you didn't i'm just saying it's
not you're a newbie wait till you're
here for 40 years oh well now i haven't
been there that long but go ahead but i
just remember um
just allowing like
you know because this this is the town
for
hollywood and business crush just crush
dreams
and everything you can put your feet up
by the way feel free to do whatever you
want and also just to be you know like
i i i knew what i wanted to do when i
came here but i
i remember just people being like oh
yeah everyone's come
everyone's come over from new zealand to
try and be in you know hollywood good
luck darling or
you know oh who do you think you are
you're just gonna come over and [ __ ] up
you know like
and i'm like i just can't be around that
right so i got my husky you got your dog
i got my beautiful husky and that was
your best friend it was like my my
homeboy for like a long time and it was
just like
i'd go we'd go to barry's boot camp
together
he'd be you know there on an audition
he'd be there when i'm crying and they
didn't get the you know the job he'd be
there when i got the job you know you
know i i still have like
grandmother's friends
who i'll i'll meet them and
they'll go so what are you doing you're
an actor it's very difficult it's very
hard and i just go with it i'm like i
know it's like are you sure you want to
do something get into this business
it's very difficult i'm like
and i could sit there and go well i was
actually you know it worked i you know
but i i don't yeah yeah it's tough
struggle is real i have the flip side in
south africa where you do one gay spot
people think you're famous really just
one spot
they were like you were in csi new york
oh my god
you were on chuck oh my word yeah like
yeah well you've done a lot of work in
these 12 years that you've been here
that's a lot of work i mean look at the
resume yeah wouldn't you say i mean you
started out doing a lot of shows in
south africa right no i started in new
zealand oh new zealand's where you
started the acting yeah so you weren't
even interested in acting when you were
in up to 17. well here's what you have
to
understand so i was born in 81 in
segregated south africa so i went to
segregated school so this was not
something that we were it wasn't it's
not even something you dreamt about you
didn't really even if your child had
remote talent in any sort of autistic
way there just was not any resources
people were just trying to survive right
so when my father got to he got a job
opportunity we moved to new zealand
and
there because the industry is
smaller the degree of separation was
smaller like i knew no one who was in
the business in
south africa when i was growing up but
you'd meet a makeup artist in new
zealand and i was doing a little bit of
modeling and then i was doing some
commercials and the way i actually got
into it i always performed in school
like i did the choir and mm-hmm
see the singing there it is that's where
it all started um
you know i never got cast in in any
place at school though like really at my
high school i know i auditioned that i
never got it was not an ego you know
squash
no i was just like
whatever um
and then
uh my family got the brunt of the one
man plays at home so i was fine i got
i got my audience right um but when i it
was a casting director who pulled me
aside and was like you should take this
seriously and
figure it out so
because i had a whole life who was this
her name's annabelle
annabelle lomas do you still contact her
do you still no but i think she's still
oh just she's i always talk about her
you thanked her ever did you ever oh no
of course yeah
you know um she put me in
i think she was the one who was costing
spadicus
wow she's the one who casts spartacus
yeah he has a funny story about that
so this is talk about totally naive that
was an intense show intense
and also we were like one of the we were
like the first like really rudy nudie
shows it was beauty like really two
episodes and it was nudie and rudy very
nerdy and rudy so um
but like so wonderful like heightened
language and like the costumes and the
world i remember walking on there just
being like oh my god what was the
language like well it's you know it's
steven tonight was the showrunner and he
was so wonderful i worked with him yeah
he directed an episode of small he's a
great guy yeah he's wonderful wonderful
and um
he you know it's like
your hat my hands serviced dominant
alone
she would not be pleased to have yours
laid upon me without her consent like
that sort of stuff yeah
um it's like [ __ ] off in like a very
polite way completely don't touch me
and
i
auditioned for that show
i i'll preface this by saying i was an
i.t recruitment consultant before all of
this and then i worked in sales and
marketing and i was a red bull girl i
had like a whole life before acting wow
and then uh
i go and i auditioned for two shows one
local and then spartacus was for stars
and american and i call my agent and i
walk out of this article's edition and
she i was like i got it and she was like
oh well i'm glad it went well but you
actually have an offer for this like
other show so wonderful like you can
take it and i was like no no no i'm
going to do the american
and she was like no leslie and this is
not her work so i was like alice
i've booked the role i'm fine you can
tell them no thank you well they haven't
called me
exactly what you said alice was like all
right darling we'll just table it for
now
and well you know 45 minutes she called
me back she goes well you got the roll
on spot i guess
wow i don't know it's a blind confidence
you know
inside of you is brought to you by nitsa
distracted driving is a serious problem
on our roadways leading to the deaths of
thousands of people and injuries in the
hundreds of thousands each year when you
take your eyes and your focus off the
road even for a second it can be deadly
not just for you but for other drivers
pedestrians bicyclists
sadly
many americans use their cell phones
while driving whether it's texting
checking emails scrolling media feeds or
any other form of distraction drivers
are putting themselves and others around
them at great risk it's important to
know that 48 states ban texting and
driving also 25 states prohibit all
drivers from using cell phones while
driving distracted drivers are not only
putting people at risk there probably
also breaking the law look guys it's
dangerous and it's dangerous to use your
cell phone behind the wheel that's why
law enforcement officers write tickets
and enforce hands-free and anti-texting
and driving laws
when you're driving put down your phone
and keep your hands on the wheel your
eyes on the road and your mind on the
task of driving remember you drive you
text
you pay
brought to you by netser inside of you
is brought to you by magic spoon my good
friends at magic spoon i i have had so
many people email me or call me and go
dude seriously i'm taking i'm going to
try this magic spoon because you're
really talking it up
i don't know what else to tell you guys
this is deliciousness at its best
if you want a cereal in the morning and
you don't want it to be full of sugar
and crap
magic spoon
is the product product
it's just the the place to go you got to
give magic spoon a chance um
i've been trying to cut down on carbs
and sugar and all this stuff unhealthy
food i realized i basically
can't eat anything anymore ryan
so uh this is a product that i can i can
eat and i can enjoy and i don't feel too
bad about it in fact i don't feel bad at
all uh tell me about some of these
ingredients ryan because it's pretty
captivating it's got zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving only
140 calories are serving its
keto-friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free low-carb
and you can build your own box why are
you kidding me i'm not kidding i like
this available flavors to build your
very own custom bundle are cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter cookies and cream
maple waffle blueberry cinnamon plus the
newly reformulated honey nut flavor that
will now be added to magic spoon's
permanent collection yeah just great
stuff guys you're gonna you're not gonna
regret this try magic spoon uh you know
growing up cereal was always a big part
of my life i woke up that's all i knew
and now it's all i have to know because
magic spoon's here and i don't have to
eat these other crappy cereals that are
full of crap go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
you've got nothing to lose here remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com iou
and use the code iou to save five
dollars off and thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
what did you get from working on that
series i mean how difficult was it
it was
well
it was challenging in that
it was only my second job so
i still when i you know when i look back
on the show i can see how green i was
and i was just and i'm still a sponge i
still look at myself as i mean i don't
think i'll ever not be the the new girl
in my mind you know yeah well i read
somewhere that you like always you love
to work with people that are i guess
better than you or more experienced so
you can learn more totally punch above
my weight like you know always because i
want to learn and i learn from even
people making mistakes or people not
making you know the choices that's
needed and scenes i learned from just
watching
um
but in that show i learned the real and
i actually pulled a lot of the
importance of what like makeup and
costume can do for a character and i
brought that into a maze on lucifer you
know because she had like you could you
could tell a lot about who she was by
how she presented herself how she walked
into a room right um
i learned
a lot about
and i didn't know i i guess it was
trusting my instincts about like
you know protecting yourself in a set
with nudity and like what you were
comfortable with and just being very uh
so you had to be nude yes so i i did you
had never done that before no bums and
boobs bombs and boobs bobs and boobs is
what i did i did not do the
merkin stuff it was not my jam were you
nervous
no i muddled before so you didn't model
nude
yeah but you're like backstage and
you're like whipping your stuff on there
yeah yeah yeah
i've never been hung up for me what was
more important was
gratuitous nudity that was not something
i was into right so
i remember
like one of my co well the costume they
wanted me to do was like basically
a piece of fabric and then you just have
this like boob out
but my chastity was being preserved
by my boss as a gift
and i was like her right-hand person so
i go well story-wise lying that doesn't
make sense
at all
i'm not walking around with a
teddy whipped out like
for an entire season right i'm not
comfortable
um this is what i'll give you
and so i that was all i was i'll give
you some sideboob i'll give you some
side boob
uh that's what i'm comfortable with but
these but i didn't i was having these
sorts of conversations
you know without pre metoo and all of
that sort of stuff and yeah i i really
do credit like being raised in cape town
honestly and like my dad was like you
don't do anything anymore you don't do
anything you don't allow anyone to make
you do something you don't want to do
like that was always drilled into my my
head
um
so
i think that's why i never got involved
in like drugs or drinking really never
have done drugs or of course i mean
we've all died but you just didn't get
no yeah i wasn't trying it no i was like
no i'm not drinking tonight i'm gonna
i have a biology test to study for
seriously and they believe yeah [ __ ]
nerd an emergency marathon murder she
wrote marathon
me and angela lansbury have a date yeah
good good for you though hey good for
you you're strong you don't have an
addictive personality
no and i have friends who do right you
know and family members who do and so i
if i didn't feel like it i didn't want
to do it but
um that show taught me a lot about
sort of
not just the craft but like the business
you know
the business because it smacks you in
your face when you come to la it's like
yeah my first team member was a was my
lawyer
really i was the first person first
person oh man because i was like oh
you gotta really like make sure you're
protected over here and not only that
it's amazing how when you have
conversations when people want to rep
you those conversations it is just they
throw everything at you
you're wonderful this is where your
career needs to go you they talk about
you like you've always wished someone
would talk about you and you're like of
course i'll sign you as my manager
gosh you really love me and this is the
thing our my our like as a south african
our natural instinct is like what do you
want
like when
i don't trust you
i don't trust you someone comes at you
like it's like what do you want
um you're making me uncomfortable yes
yes
so
i uh
no it was is this a great this was a it
was a good show to like dip my toe in
you know and then the period the period
was wonderful yeah
that's amazing why now you know i read
that you didn't go back
what were the reasons you didn't come
back
i was a local hire
when i was college on spartacus and when
i
came
to the states and i got representation
and
you know i really wanted like a sad
contract you know
and um
andy at that point
was sick and we knew like he wasn't
coming back and it
for me like
i had a manager who did not handle the
situation well and i fired him
subsequently
um after that but
uh
i really wanted to i had that golden
ticket i had the visa i had a working 01
visa
and i was like i just i gotta back
myself i've never not done that so you
could have gone back and done it and
just played it as a local hire and made
way less money i still to this day don't
get residuals on that show
yeah so you know i think that's a
misconception about a lot of shows like
people think you know you get a lot of
residuals from things those dry up
pretty quickly and especially with
streaming now they haven't figured it
out so yeah you know smallville's all
over the place and nothing or other you
know sure sure um but it was like i was
negotiating like as a local and i mean
this is no disrespect to the local
industry because new zealand has got
wonderful crews um and actors but we
were as actors and i don't know if it's
still the same because i haven't worked
there since but like bare minimum like
negotiating for a trailer you know just
uh
and you're about to do like a nude scene
or something like that and these were
the kinds of things that were being used
in negotiations and i was just i
remember coming over in like two weeks
within two weeks i booked like a
recurring role in csi and i booked chuck
so like one day it was like an assassin
with you know um
zach levi and like in
um
you know uh fighting yvonne and and then
in the afternoon i'm kidnapped by neo
and you know i was like wow this is
hollywood
man yeah you're really doing it totally
and but i had
i it was so much it was so collaborative
you know from everything from hair to
makeup and then i was like i made more
money
just
doing that so
a lot of people are like oh you know i
think at the time it broke there was
this like she was greedy she was like
i'm like i wasn't greedy i just wasn't
they they could just make you look so
bad totally i remember when i talked
about ad nauseam but then you know just
like he left small though what is he
doing after why would he i go i didn't
[ __ ] leave how many times do i have
to tell you i got mad at kevin smith i
go kevin why did you say i you know
that so i i didn't leave i i was
supposed to do six seasons i did seven
is that leaving that's giving them
another [ __ ] year man yeah but you
know it's no matter how you do it you
look like the bad guy they like to paint
that picture and i do i do i mean it was
so like a such a
you know non
thing and there was they replaced the
role and the another wonderful actress i
got to have her take on it and no hard
feelings at all definitely a hard thing
to go through as an actor and then
another wonderful lesson like no one's
irreplaceable right so good lesson to
learn there um yes but what happened was
within that two weeks i met
jonathan littman and christiane reed my
brockheimer producers
on lucifer
and i did that and when i auditioned for
lucifer they go oh we remember you from
csi thank you so much for like that was
so wonderful so like
had i gone back i wouldn't have done csi
probably right and didn't you replace
ironically someone on
lucifer did um yeah if for whatever
reason it didn't work out at the table
read and um
and
uh
my understanding was there was just
creative differences and like what the
character was going to be
and
i went to that audition and like full
leather bra leather pants
the girls in the waiting room were like
wow no one else was doing that no you
just went for it i went for it
same way
oh my god this reminds me of my very
first acting gig uh
i was supposed to be this princess from
this fictional island right in new
zealand called a diplomatic immunity
right
i had no idea what i was doing on that
show but i went in like
bikini top
just
because she's supposed to she was
supposed to be protesting at like a
pageant
and
they looked at me like what are you
doing and i was like well i'm just i
don't know
trying [ __ ]
and i got the role
you know it's when you just go above and
beyond sometimes it backfires i i did an
audition for mike judge and i thought
you know he's weird he does a lot of
weird [ __ ] i'm gonna go in there and i
went in so weird and i brought like a
ceramic
dog like a little ceramic dog that i
thought it would be would be funny for
the character and i just set it on the
desk and i didn't really make a lot of
eye contact with mike and i just
kept in this character in this voice and
then afterwards i go
mike to my manager at the time i go how
did i do he goes
i'm going to be honest with you man
you're really scared mike judge you
really made him uncomfortable wow
what how did i make mike judge
uncomfortable
and so
you got to take those chances though you
take a chance and you're like because it
might just work and it might not yeah
but do you do you get nervous before
auditions totally you do i still do i
mean now it's changed a lot because now
we're self-taping right yeah good old
covet and it's got its pros and cons you
know you get to tape as many times or
whatever um
but
i used to have this really hardcore
nervous tic like my leg would shake and
my bottom lip look quiver always
in the beginning my first audition in
los angeles i took a giant dump in the
room like stank that thing out it was so
bad what do you mean in the bathroom no
in the actual room like metaphorical
dump oh like guys come on like who's
[ __ ] in audition rooms well my
friend bobby lee actually did that's why
i say that he actually [ __ ] in some
guy's office oh no that's why i was like
did she really [ __ ] i love this girl wow
she took a dump in a casting room
but i went in and we were not used to
10 pages the night before like this is
just like not in new zealand you have
the casting director a camera you get a
reasonable enough time to learn it and
you're completely off book and it's like
i don't know like the normal way right
for me
i go in and i'm like fumbling with the
papers and i'm like i'm so and i'm this
is my very first and i and again i'm so
sorry it's just in you know new zealand
we don't and i say all of this stuff and
this again a wonderful lesson i thank
this producer with my whole heart
he was like well you're not in new
zealand now
so thank you very much
and like i had to leave i didn't cry i
was just like all right were you
thinking about it
i was like man up you're in hollywood no
you're in l.a wow you gotta like man up
you're not new zealand anymore yeah
are you glad he said that yes you are
100
not at the moment
well that i'm not in new zealand what do
you mean not in the moment when he said
that uh uh
no i was embarrassed i was i felt awful
you know but i
uh again think i was raised by a
wonderful man
who was just like take the knock on the
chin you know figure out what you have
to do and then you get back up again
right uh
was your mom tough like that too yes my
mom was hard my mom is very nurturing
she is very nurturing
um
and but my dad i was like my dad's son
for 11 years until my brother came along
so like i was like changing tires and
wow you know
playing playing cricket
playing field hockey do you like ice
hockey
no oh i can't i can't follow i'm like
where's the puck thing like i could
teach you in five minutes but also
here's my other thing also
why the fighting why they smushed faces
against the thing
why is the knocking of the teeth like a
thing i'm gonna just be brief on this
okay there's an emotion when you're
playing and you're moving playing in a
sport that's so fast moving right and
you bump into each other and you get
kind of like you know it's almost like
you know like you know hey watch where
you're going watch your stick man by
accident someone's stick gets near your
face you're like hey watch your f
instead and it's just like it's it's a
beautiful sport but i think sometimes
you know it's legal to hit them against
the board and take the puck as long as
you you don't take more than three
strides or it's a charging penalty so
you can hit them and mostly as long as
they're clean remember they're you're
trying to be clean clean hits
cleaning
though
sometimes there's fights and it
sometimes changes the momentum of a game
sometimes if you're losing three nothing
you're embarrassed you're in your home
crowd this is just booing you and all
sudden you drop the gloves with the
other team you like you look at him and
if there's a man the man kind of uh
there's sort of a respect thing we're
like you want to go they say that you
want to go he's like sure let's go throw
them down and they fight and they're
totally cool afterwards
they just you know they and they fight
so it's it's just something that i
i don't know i love hockey i'm more of a
rugby girl rugby they don't even wear
helmets they just yeah but they don't
they're not like they're
so dangerous
yeah they don't wear helmets and they
have least concussions
do they have less concussions they do i
don't know how that's possible no they
do
well it's because they like they learn
proper tackling techniques and there's
less temptation to smash them
because what happens to people with uh
like see now we're gonna get into the
football rugby thing which my american
friends are like shut up leslie and i'm
like listen don't try and teach me
football i don't know football i'm here
for the guac and madonna okay that's
what i'm here for i
know they hate me my husband hates me my
my manager he's like a big football guy
he's like come on
um
but
i think yeah exactly what you're saying
the helmet and the pads you feel
invincible it's like putting on like
super armor like
you know rugby it's got to be strategic
also it's the like stop start of the
game that i don't get it's like wait now
why like
why are the madonna headsets there did
they not figure out how to make like
smaller mic do you talk about football
yes like why what like
like
why is there a commercial every like
five minutes
it's just sort of yeah the flow i like
the phases of rugby like watching
like a beautiful team to watch new
zealand
the all blacks really it's like watching
they're called the all blacks the all
blacks and you should see them do the
haka it's like a traditional maori like
warrior i've never been to a rugby
conference come on is it a contest
google this [ __ ] you just google a haka
it'll like pump you up totally if you
want to get juice if you're like i got
this audition with mike whatever judge
that joke i gotta see him again and like
i gotta psych myself up go watch a haka
like it's
inspiring it is all right i'll i'll i'll
check it out now yeah go ahead but yeah
this is the
i see what you're saying but i think
have you ever been to an ice hockey game
i have all right i think if somebody
explains it to you right and they
explain you what's going on and what's
happening i think it's very different
two good teams battle each other it's
extremely fast it's a it's a beautiful
sport imagine you're not just running
you're not walking you're on these
little blades moving extremely fast yeah
and it's exhausting and with one minute
on the ice that you need to break
because that's how hard you're skating
yeah i don't know maybe some hockey team
would like to invite me to watch them
and i might change my mind any hockey
teams out there
inside of you is brought to you by true
bill uh it's about time that an app came
around like this
this is an app that you want to listen
to this is going to save you money
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forget forgot about how many
times have you like subscribed to
something all of a sudden you're like
i've been paying months of this
i've been paying this
i don't even use this anymore whether
it's an app or whether it's a streaming
service or you've lost so much money and
truebill will help you you'll stop
you'll save money with this i don't know
why everybody doesn't do this on average
people save up to 720
a year with true bill because companies
make subscriptions hard to cancel true
bill makes it incredibly simple just
link your accounts and true bill will
cancel your unwanted subscriptions in
one tap and your true bill concierge is
there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to and did you know that truebill has
over 2 million users and helped save
them over 100 million dollars wow what
are we waiting for what are you waiting
for don't fall for subscription scams
start canceling today at truebill.com
inside
t-r-u-e-b-i-l-l truebuild.com inside go
right now truebill.com
inside it could save you thousands a
year truebill.com
inside
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy i
can't tell you how many emails or texts
or messages i get
from people telling me that better help
is helping them
and i really love that i love uh
talking about something that works that
helps people
that is a sponsor on the podcast where
we talk about mental health
it's very important ryan's still with
better help i'm still a better help and
it's still
helping still helping help i like
hearing that you know people don't
always realize that physical symptoms
like headaches
teeth grinding even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
overeating stress shows up in all kinds
of ways and in a world that's telling
you to do more sleep less and grind all
the time here's your reminder to take
care of yourself to do less and maybe
try some therapy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to ryan you like to see people i do i
think it helps i do too i like to see
the person i'm talking to but that's
just me if you don't feel like seeing a
face you don't have to you could also
text you could have it you could do
whatever you want it's so much more
affordable than in-person therapy
trust me on that one uh going in uh
in-person therapy is is so expensive
it's i'd say some cases it's triple
quadruple the cost of better health by
far uh you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see if online therapy can help
lower your stress i believe it really
can truly this podcast is sponsored by
better help and inside of you listeners
get 10 percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash
in sign give therapy a shot
better help online therapy
now you're uh speaking of which we were
talking about sports and stuff but you
are in great shape you're always i see
these companies like youtube things
where it's like mma workout with leslie
ann brand i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that you're like do you think if you
didn't work out and you didn't do all
these health things
you think you'd be in a bad place you
think health really or like working out
and all these things really stimulate
you and help you in achieving what you
want to well i've always been an athlete
so you know
i swam competitively
i played field hockey i played tennis
basketball athletics
um
my dad was a lifeguard i come from like
a family of sportsmen your dad was a
lifeguard yeah wow
in the shark-infested oceans of cape
town south africa did you see a lot of
sharks yeah did you see a lot of sharks
yeah i went shark cage diving i i mean
this is hello africa welcome any really
close encounters where you're worried
like oh no okay no no no no go ahead but
you respect the ocean right so you're
you know um but i think that being
physically active
it is important to not just my physical
health but like my mental health i mean
there's all these scientific studies you
can like endorphins are released you
feel better you have more energy um so
i don't
feel good physically or mentally if i'm
not moving and active you know be it
i mean just before i came here i was at
my trainers uh who's like you know 15
minutes from you and
but i'm like i had to get it in because
my husband's away i haven't worked out
for three days properly i actually had
an acl knee surgery like three and a
half months ago so
i'm like committed to the
my second one rehab and yeah rehab and
working it you know work out but it's um
yeah it's a big part of my family's
lifestyle is
being active and healthy
um and not to the extent where i'm like
not having you know fun right you know
because i know people who are like i
ought to just be clean oh it's hard it's
hard the older you get it's just hard to
get in that gym and like [ __ ] man it's
just like
i don't want to do legs ever and legs
are the one i mean it's just
you do feel better after you do it you
feel like a sense of accomplishment yeah
where do you work out here i just i have
a little gym downstairs a small gym but
i probably should get out of there
that's what i'm saying yeah i know
you're gonna save it for me like it's
why group fitness was like a big thing
for me like
um or being with other people because i
don't need a trainer standing over me
going like
that
right you know i
i just need to get out
and be around i like the gym i like
seeing other people and um but yeah i
would
i would i would try and
you know go see someone
go see paulo my trainer that's great
he's great he's a transfer he's
expensive isn't he
yes i bet he's like 200 an hour yeah
more yeah 300 an hour
no not 250. maybe i don't know 225.
that's a lot it's a lot i mean it's a
lot but is he is he worth it
totally paulo's like
body transformer you know his his
speciality i mean he transformed tom tom
went from like
you know season one and two you're
talking about welling uh no oh tom
tom ellis the lead like season one and
two
you know and tom's always like a
handsome dude but like he gave him like
a superhero body like came season four
people were like damn what happened
really yeah
and
he's working i mean he's done it with a
lot of cast members um he's just he's
very specific he's like me
we're both you know we eat plant-based
health and wellness is like very
important to us
uh
we don't you know people who don't work
out for me i'm like it's not that i
think i don't judge you at all but i go
god if you only knew how wonderful this
is how good this is for you yeah i know
it really is it's just mentally too
you know i i deal with anxiety and i
deal with other things yeah did you ever
deal with those things have you ever
been depressed or you had anxiety or
dealt with that stuff or not really yeah
you know i think
uh
there was one time in my life it was
very very
challenging my dad was my mother
suffered
suffers from
uh depression um and so
uh
she
has her coping mechanisms and you know
she grew up in a time and in a country
where
therapy was not available and
south africans can be very like i'll
just
deal with it it's part of life just
sweep it under the rug and keep going
you know
and
we're not we we can sometimes i think
the general consensus is sometimes like
it's self-indulgent
you know
um
but and i understand why because that's
life is so different there you know it's
so difficult to like stop worrying about
yourself we've got other issues here
we've got social issues we're literally
trying to put food on the table like
there's like we're literally just trying
to like snap out of it exactly exactly
um so but i in high school so she went
through a really challenging time in my
final year of high school and i was
you know 17 i was taking care of
my mother
you know cooking for everyone my brother
who
um you know had really bad adhd
um
looking after my grandparents at the
same time for a 17 year old it was like
a lot and like that was hard that was
like a tough time i was like oh
okay and then i would say
another it was like post baby when i was
just because i went back to work six
weeks after i had kingston and i was
really struggling to
juggle my responsibilities to the show
be a good wife
keep this baby alive yeah
be an actor like
go back to work not physically feeling
or looking like you think that's
postpartum is that right i think i had a
little bit of that
i think and i don't think i realized it
until much later
i actually wrote a little
i wrote something about it for self
magazine about just it was it had to do
with like you know women's right to
choose and just like what i experienced
um
but
what do you mean what you experienced
just well i exp well what i experienced
as a new mother and when i made the dis
you know like what an abortion is for
like a woman and why we make these
decisions right um
and i think the more we talk about stuff
like that like
the more
people feel like oh it's not just me you
know she seems to have have it all
together and like wonderful family but
we all have challenges you know you just
never know what's going on in someone's
life right
um
but
to your point working out helps you know
getting in the gym for me or doing
something physical going on a hike
you know get yourself out there just
just go for a walk do something yeah and
my friends who really do struggle with a
lot of anxiety and depression like they
talk about how
a win for them some days is just having
a shower i'm like take the win take the
win take the shower take the win take
the win it's okay day by day yeah
that's tough so lucifer i mean is
lucifer over now done it's done how do
you feel about
we
that
six seasons right yes i was there from
the pilot from the pilot on i mean you
were there through the cancellations
through the revivals to the you've been
through it all
i don't think any show has been canceled
twice was it canceled twice yeah that's
seldom is that and the fans got the show
back on on the air yeah
that's just incredible crazy
social media it's insane what is how do
you feel when you did your last episode
when you knew this was the end because
this is a big part of your life big part
of my life how did it affect you
it was
it was incredibly like sad
you know to
there's a familiarity with uh
with
the lot
10 minutes from my house i sleep in my
own bed
some days i finish i can pick my kid up
from school you know just like having
that people are watching yeah people are
watching like to get on the show people
watch and really like you know yeah big
fan base and not only watch we were just
recently like
forbes were like you were the
top watch show for netflix in 2021 or
something are you serious yeah so like
binge or something so like
to
i don't think you really
you know realize it
like we i didn't we had no i had no idea
what we were making until
the show was on for a few years and
then i realized when i would travel
abroad on you know
what that fan base was right because
you're you're just making this little
show in los angeles right and then you
put it out into the world and
hopefully see what happens yeah most of
the time it's a piece of [ __ ] and every
once in a while you get a little golden
nugget yeah so it's you know it's had
it's had this like uh this crazy life
cycle the show um i was really sad to
i loved our cruise and we got to do
um
we got to have crews in both vancouver
and la
and they were honestly like the backbone
of that show
because
obviously it was fun it was a fun set to
go to and
and i think that was something we were
all really proud of was guest stars
wanted to come and work on the show crew
said no to jobs and hoping that the show
would get another season you know that's
a that's a big compliment
and then
just you know add covet on top of that
just how much they were busting their
ass we had i mean i just hung out with
like jackie
who's my stand-in like she came over and
helped me out to walk my dogs it was
like jackie i need help like and then
she said i'm like let's watch a movie
let's watch bond so you know we hung out
i went on a hike with my makeup art
artist hidvig like you take these
wonderful people with you
had
she's the terminator of makeup you look
beautiful darling um
so you missed the crew a lot i missed
the crew who's the one person in the
cast you're just like i miss all of them
but the one i miss is
that's it
you know it it's on your you want to say
it but you can't
i can't say it
you can't say it i don't want to say it
how about
top no you can't say top three
somebody's gonna someone's gonna be i'm
not i'm not even top three
what the [ __ ] are you doing here's what
i will say is
uh
you know it's where to get a group
of people
as actors sixers and who were still as
committed to the work
you know yeah six years down like we all
were really like we have to go out we
have to put our best we have to show up
every day
and you're allowed you know obviously
there are days where you know
people are not feeling their best or
personal stuff is happening in their
lives but
99 of the time
you're showing up there and it's fun
yeah it's like you're you're getting
it's a wonderful rally back and forth in
these scenes and our show was like silly
but then heartfelt at the same time but
then had like badass action
but then super goofy was it the first
time you ever had to kiss a woman was on
lucifer
i mean on on tv
she's
always dropping those bombs
[Laughter]
but it wasn't the first time in real
life i can't
in real life in real life uh
was it my first time on tv no i don't
think on tv probably in spartacus you
probably did something no i didn't no i
i'm just wondering if it was like you
know it's the first time you do
something it's we you know i i've had to
kiss a man before it's never been made
of course it was actually i did in
college
we were playing spin the bottle
and uh
we guys had to kiss guys if girls kiss
girls that was just the rule so i was
like fine i think it's weird i want to
see girls kiss girls so let's go and
then they spun the bottle on me and i
had to kiss
you know
matthew semrick and i was like he had
great lips i wasn't into it matthew
simmering great lips we kissed each
other i was like hey man your soft
kisser and now i know why you get all
the hotties
you know uh i had to kiss rourke kissed
him
anyway back to you uh
yeah i don't no but it was not weird for
me it wasn't weird you kind of get used
to it where you're like oh no i love
this person
no yeah but also it's like it's the work
you know i mean that's the that's the
thing about
actors my husband's an actor too and
you know we gotta kiss other people you
just gotta get used to it do you ever go
home and go god it was really great
kissing that guy
why the [ __ ] would i do that i know how
rude would that be
did you imagine but you know what it's
i'll tell you what there is something to
be said about like people go people
always the response from actors that
i've talked to is like it's a job man
it's just a job i'm just going through
i've seen people
not
have it be more than a job like i see
i've seen people have things develop you
know it is a job you just have to
like you have to be truthful
and professional and professional yes
but i'm just saying like those days
where i didn't kiss kristen crook
on smallville
uh i'm not saying those were
maybe they were worse days
than the days where i actually had to
kiss her it wasn't a bad thing that i
had to kiss her
to chris i was professionally no she
knows i always joke about it but i'm
like you know it doesn't suck you know
all i care is fresh breath man that's my
thing oh that's me too if you have a bad
breath you'll come out listen i will
literally have a conv a sidebar
conversation with your makeup artist and
i'll be like i'm you can you just make
sure that there's mints in there packed
yeah i think they had a [ __ ] sandwich
before lunch i'm like can you please and
i i i've been known to ask people like
hey so we have kissing scene would you
mind just like brushing your teeth
before flossing flossing
turpentine whatever you yeah girl that's
what i'm talking about yeah just take it
down the throat yeah there's not nothing
worse when you have a sex scene and
you're just like oh boy
and people okay they don't get it so i
had this all right so so on spartacus
this actor
who
he would go and run around the [ __ ]
looters like
like gotta get my jet gotta get my
muscles you know up he'd run around nude
no like run around the lewdest oh the
loose right
can you someone get the ex body spray or
whatever musk like what that's
unprofessional so unprofessional
like so and like sweat and then you've
got it like i was so i'm with you yeah
please
i'm i'm very yeah it's just
b.o and like mouth odor yeah come on
guys yeah come on wherever you are for
whomever
get it together yeah um i have to ask
you about the morgan freeman project the
district six yeah because i saw some did
have you obviously met him
because you have this project
the the listen well leslie oh my lord
and bran it's
wild to know that
i and i'm gonna geek out
man i have to geek out so it's wild to
know you know you have this idea and
it's about your community and your
people and it's about like
history and like a place where your
mother grew up
and
you write it down
seven years ago
and then you just keep telling the story
telling the story and
then you go to morgan freeman's
production company and they're like we
love it
like eight years later working with it
with my with my partner who's irish
adrian adrian cunningham from vancouver
see look at your accent hello adrian
cunningham from vancouver
um so
well he's from dublin actually um so
but him and i you know this irish and
south african kind of coming together
and
it was
it's wonderful we are in where we're at
right now is we found a writer
you you've got projects like and
development you know what this process
is like right i have full respect for it
it's tough man i have so many projects
that i just love and i'm like why isn't
this selling or why is this taking so
long you don't get it you just go hey
man you do this because you love it and
if something happens with it yeah it'll
be in so it's a very personal story it's
never been told before it's actually the
the area that it takes place in district
six is what the movie district nine was
based on
um
but it's but what we're leaning into and
it is sit and you know apartheid but
what we're really leaning into is the
joy that people had despite what was
happening around them
so i think we've you know especially
these last two years you've seen a lot
of trauma porn tv that's it's just too
much it's like dwight i think ted lasso
has done so well you know it's just like
a really inspiring heartfelt
show that's funny and it's good makes
you feel good right you know um i mean
people say that i have to see it you
watch it [ __ ] do you like football
jesus like real football where you use
your feet
uh
sure sure
come on no i guess i do i mean i do i
like i like sports i'll check it out
yeah it's funny um
and
but yeah so we're leaning more
you know into that and telling
you know stories from africa that are
not just depressing like we're just
we're as a continent we're more than
that we're more than famine and poverty
and war and like it's a beautifully rich
continent that has many different
countries
with many different cultures what's that
movie uh it won an oscar tutsi no no
maybe that didn't win in oscar south
africa
would say he's an italian actor and it
was through the holocaust and through
world war ii and he was with his
beautiful life is beautiful so you know
how he's always trying to make things
light and happy and fun during the
horrible times
so in a sense like that but not as not
as dark
we're gonna be truthful to what was
happening right but it's a beautiful
love story between two sisters um
you know female focused
and
um
uh
the the writer that were
that were talking to her movie barakat
is
the official selection for south africa
for the oscars and the in the
international film section and she did
a very similar thing in that she took
a muslim family and just told a really
heartfelt story but they just happen to
be muslim like it's not a it's just a
family story right
and i think
you know for coming from where i come
from
and now living in the states we are so
fortunate that we grow up surrounded by
you know this community of district 6
had
christian atheists jews muslim anyone
and everyone protestants whatever like
living together harmoniously from people
from all walks of life different races
like they exist their their mere
existence was defiance to
the government right and that says
something about the human spirit and
what we're able to overcome
um
so
and then i think there's also a great
opportunity as we've seen with you know
shows like watchmen where you can
educate people within the first five
minutes of your pilot on you know tulsa
oklahoma
yeah
and you but you do it from an from an
inter you know it's entertaining but
also you learn history and then that's
what people were talking about did you
know that that happened you know like
that that's something it's amazing how
most people don't realize exactly a lot
of the events that happen in history i'm
probably one of them there's some things
that i'm just like oh i don't know
anything about that yeah and i should
there's so many things are you a big
documentary watching i love documentary
too love documentaries me too yeah we
will compare maybe you'll send me
something to watch i'll send you
something to watch did you watch misha
and the wolves recently no
is it good it's
you have to email me that yeah email me
that i've got some too that
that are deep water i think it's called
oh it's about these
these sailors in 1969 that they race
around the world and they start in
england and it will take them a year
and they all start at different times
but it's all based on the fastest time
and who'll you know have the fastest
time to do it
and this one guy who's more of a weekend
sailor
he shouldn't have been on the boat and
he and you're by yourself you don't have
any crew you're all alone out to sea for
a year a year
and you use you know uh
you journal and you record things uh
and it's his story
what have i done it is like i got
goosebumps even thinking about it i've
seen it twice and it's just like
i just love the trailer
donald crowhurst sailed around the world
and into
oblivion or some [ __ ] like that forgot
what it was donald crowhurst but you
have to see that i'm really good i'm
into it i'm into it all right these are
uh this is uh [ __ ] talking with leslie
and brandt talk some [ __ ] this is uh
patrons my lovable patrons you go to
patreon.com society you support the
podcast these are people that do that
and they have questions so
they could be rapid fire okay dana s any
chance of now i always know as maize is
it mazakin
it's mazukin right any chance of
mazokine spinoff i think that would be
dope as f
listen you wanna i don't know
raise your
social media
it's happened before
i say anything can happen but you know
for our show and our world i think we
ended on a good
you know vibe but
maybe not a show maybe like a movie like
a netflix movie or something i don't
know
sebastian k in real life are you an
angel or a demon
just knowing you'd probably see
somewhere in between i'm south african
let's just leave it there
i'm south africa figure it out
danny fantastic guest would love to hear
her thoughts on filming the musical
episode of lucifer her version of bad to
the bone is amazing
you know
i
honest to god i was really scared about
that episode because
i was like are we are we jumping the
shark is it like
are we like doing that thing like why
why are we like you know and we are a
very musical show
you know tom sings the playlist is like
a huge pot
but i will say
it was fun
um
it was really fun to do i
i had got to learn choreography and you
know um i was not sure about the mashup
between
tlc and back to the bone i was like ooh
how is this going to work you know but
that's just typical actor [ __ ] right
we're judging the minute we get the page
judge judge judge
um
but it was a lot of fun it was a lot of
lots of time to shoot yeah ablef what is
the best and worst memory that is
attached to a potential paranormal
supernatural experience you have had
growing up from south africa to across
the globe
i i have no idea but that was the
question
what is the best worst memory
that is attached to a potential
paranormal supernatural experience that
you have had growing up
from south africa to across the globe i
i've never heard paranormal you've never
had a supernatural something you're like
oh my god this is weird how did this
happen
how is this no nothing you've had
nothing weird happen
i guess they asked that because the
whole lucifer thing and they're thinking
nothing that scared you like how did
nothing
no was south africa was supposed to be a
haunted country
we have demons
south africa has demons
i mean yes they were the government
there you go there you go perfect
perfect answer for that one will f
eyebrow scar
real real or fake real real brother 11
years old
had a mug he was like in his walking
ring or whatever and he's like
and typical south african dad it's fine
just put some water on it yeah you'll be
okay never got stitches but my dad did
that with my lips split my lip open a
garage door a piece of glass came down
from the garage and split my lip open
this one's from hockey but and he's like
you're fine i'm like dad i'm gushing
blood he's like no he's so cheap he
wouldn't even take me to the doctor
i'm telling you it's cheap no my well i
don't think it was my parents were cheap
they really couldn't afford it
they just couldn't afford it it was
really good but uh
but it healed in like a perfect line so
you know
i love it because it reminds me of my
brother
i love him little lisa what time period
would you travel to if you were given a
time machine
hmm
well not
the roman times because i'd be a slave
um
um
i don't know i think i've always loved
like the 70s you know just in terms of
like fashion
like
music
laid back free yeah
60s 70s
yeah
i mean yeah
a lot of that
depends on
your race too about how fun
that's true things would be you know but
uh yeah i love that like i grew up on my
parents old like sort of
70s 80s music what's your favorite song
or favorite artist or top three or
someone you've really listened to oh
that's right i'm like
major adele fan major really yeah but
i'm talking old school like 70s like
what your parents were in okay so i grew
up listening
to
[Music]
you're gonna laugh i grew up listening
to the carpenters i love the carpenters
there's another song that they have
i love
uh
i grew up with like aretha franklin you
know
um
barry white teddy pendergross um
my grandfather
loved old blue eyes um
frankie
um
music was always a big part of like what
what
you know was happening in my house
it's called for all we know oh do you
know oh yes
you do
i probably have it on my phone
[Music]
here we go come on
[Music]
strangers
in many ways
all right that's karen
oh what a great song yeah yeah the
carpenters we've we have we've got a
lifetime to say i knew you well oh my
god what a great line
yeah we've got a lifetime to say i know
you will
this has been really fun this is good
did you have fun oh my gosh this is so
easy it is i mean it's it's nice when
it's easy wait so what did welling tell
you about me uh let me see i got it
right here he says
badass
he's a badass uh
you know you play a bounty hunter you
totally pull it off he doesn't know if
you were pregnant or you just had it
i just had it were you pregnant
just have you just had that
pregnant or just had it he doesn't know
but he says uh how you jumped into the
role one scene you had a knife fight
after being around you he said you were
so intense that she might actually stab
him that's hilarious he was concerned
but says so much fun loves you loves
your husband so do you remember that
knife scene yeah
yeah
were you pregnant at the time or just
come back
so that's c and you just went right for
it the old tenderloins were still tender
are you fun on set like i mean
after a take do you snap into fun leslie
ann brandt are you are you still a demon
no we goof around oh you do that's
important no no we goof around a lot but
i will say
uh
when i'm in it or where i'm like when my
character's being aggressive or whatever
it's not hard for me to channel that
part and i just think that that's just
my south africanness it's just girls are
raised to like cut you from birth right
watch you bleed out that's right
yeah because we have to know but i love
welling and i love jess
we uh we hung out with him at the polo
and we were laughing because we're like
look at us we're just parents we have a
date ourselves we can have like yummy
champagne all we're doing is talking
about how obsessed we are with our kids
because we love them and we miss them
and it's been an hour that's nice i know
what's next anything coming up are you
just kind of taking a minute to breathe
we're
so i have both those projects in
development and then there's some things
you know stirring hence i couldn't come
the other day but um yeah you met with a
big director can't say who it was
[Music]
so you know you can't even say that
well let's just see what happens we'll
just see you know but uh
but yeah i'm in that great phase where
you can take
you finish the show for six years and
yeah you wanna
yeah yeah
i like it yeah
ryan do you have anything this is really
fun yeah what you got ryan what do i
have
nothing nothing um
i wish i had something i really wish i
prepared something what was the last
song you sang in your car
ooh adele adele what song
um
a woman like me
uh-huh uh he gave someone that's one of
those women like me
you get that stank
[Music]
but it's like
expensive i saw her at the lakers game
last week she was just sitting there i
was like oh there's adele she's cool
dude i've never been to a basketball
game really ever i got to do that maybe
i'll i'll take you in your hubby do you
got do you got hookups
i i i'm not bragging but i do i do have
a hookup come on a little hookup come
through
i have to go to the game with you though
come let's go
are you inviting me to the game yeah
let's go we'll take your seat yeah and
now you can sit with me
that would be fun yeah it's it's a lot
of fun i think you have a blast yeah i'd
love to meet chris where are you from uh
i was born in new york grew up in
indiana southern indiana
yeah yeah i don't have a really a new
york accent i could turn it on when i go
you know a little bit he's massachusetts
lived in new york for like pack your cat
and have it yet kind of gang
what
pack your cat and have it yet is that
how they talk i don't know no
new yorkers no no no no boston i doesn't
say
my brother-in-law lives in boston really
did you talk like that quincy now he's
from massachusetts his wife's from
quincy julie she's got my sister-in-law
she's got
she uh what does she say always fish and
shapes was the fish and chips thing you
said
no she's i love that she has a saying oh
god i forget but no her her accent is
like
that's that's one that i say fish and
chips again fashion shops fashion shows
don't worry
i love this thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you today hopefully you'll
come back i will any time awesome this
is a blast
thanks
i think uh if you liked that episode i
urge you to say hey you know what
rosenbaum's not bad let's uh follow him
on the uh twitter and the uh and
subscribe and write a review i liked her
i liked her too i did she was a joy you
always remember the really good
interviews of the interviews where you
like someone yeah it's not that i don't
like anyone no but i liked her no she
had good stories and you know she did
south africa
mm-hmm
yeah she had some really great stories
she just seems just a fun person to be
around yeah uh if you enjoy the episode
like i said write a review
subscribe we can watch on youtube
subscribe there
follow us we have a clips channel too
um so you can watch highlights of
episodes later on in the week if you
know you didn't get around to but i hope
you watch the episode that's that's the
most important thing we want to keep
this podcast going
um join patreon to support the podcast
in many other ways i love the community
thank you
patreon.com inside of you and if you're
still listening listen to the very
beginning and i talk about the cons and
i talk about the inside of you online
store and all that but right now we're
going to get into
by the way i was at the magic castle
this last last night oh yeah
yeah i'm a member at the magic castle
and i saw some magic ryan
at the magic castle let me tell you
something what
i've never seen
i've been in the magic castle probably
four times i've seen a lot of magic
i saw something last night this guy
johnny
palmville or johnny johnny knoxville no
johnny got hit on the nuts palmer johnny
palmer something older gentleman
sleight of hand
i've never seen anything like it i've
never ever seen anything like it me my
friends
a gasp
it it was just
astonishing what he was doing
he had this thing where there's these
three cups and people turn it over and
they turn it back
and then there's three chickens little
chickens in there
you know there's no way he did it he
made a deal with the devil
he made a gtd deal with the devil
that's a goddamn warlock
it was i i'm telling you i'm going to
bring you the magic castle you and
amanda we've been with you before yes
but we're going to go again he's when
he's there
let's give a shout out to all the top
tier patrons who support this podcast in
extra ways i love you all thanks for uh
bringing this show to life and keeping
it around nancy d leah s sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h nico p robert
b jason w kristen k allison el raj c
joshua d cjp jennifer n stacy l gen s
jamal f janelle b kimberly e mike e
eldaan sopremo
99 more ramirez santiago m chad w liam p
janine r my p
maddie s belinda and chris h dave h
spider-man chase
damn right sheila g brad d ray
h correct tabitha t tom and liliana a
talia m betsy d chad l rochelle marion
meg k trav l dan and big stevie w
correct angel m rhiannon c corey k super
sam correct dev nixon correct michelle a
jeremy c andy t cody r gav
correct mundo ryan david c john b brandy
dio
voor voor is correct camille s the c the
c
joey m willie f adelaide n omri we have
uh lena n design otg eugene and leah
chris p nikki g corey patricia heather l
we've got uh the last few here
say the last for best best for last oh
yes they're all the best oh yeah uh we
got jake b james b bob at eddie ed a
ed a space a eddie
uh alec abel abel i got it i finally got
it it's able it is able correct like
cain and abel i've been messing this
this person's name up for quite some
time uh joshua b
tony g sean r megan t mel s orlando c
john b caroline r darren b rob e paul c
christine ace s
ace
sarah s eric h spring jennifer r hannah
h and dylan t
you guys make this podcast possible i
couldn't do it without you i love you
thank you cumulus westwood one thank you
my man ryan right here thick and thin
almost knocking [ __ ] over you almost
knocked jason voorhees over man because
it's a
theme that's a thing that happens quite
often people almost knock his [ __ ] over
uh thanks to uh my producer bryce can do
without you buddy and uh jason jason you
edit the [ __ ] out of the show and uh uh
i really appreciate you you gotta come
hang with us sometime for god's sakes
jason all right uh that's about
wraps it up wraps us up
um
from myself michael rosenbaum here in
the hollywood hills of california
hollywood hills california right here's
here
bye-bye we love you guys have a great
week man be good to yourselves i always
say it but don't be so hard on
yourselves take a deep breath let's all
take a deep breath two three
not everything's that important sorry i
was yawning through the deep breath
yeah good young good got a good yeah
that's good ryan and i need a nap we've
done a lot of stuff today and a nap we
love you join us next week um please
join us and follow us and subscribe
thank you bye
[Music]